انا حياتي طول عمري كنت بحب الموضع وكنت
بحب
الفاشن في اول العشرينات مريت
بحاجه في حياتي الشخصيه كانت مؤلمه شويه ف
حيلتي النفسيه ادمرت بس يوم الايام نزلت
قابلت جدتي على القهوه وقالت لي ايه ده
ياسمينه انا معرفتكيش بقول لها اه يعني
اصل جسمي اغير وشعري بيقع وحالتي حاله
يعني قالت لي لا اصل انت عمرك ما كتت
بتلبسي
كده كلمه اثرت معايا قوي يعني يعني ايه
عمري ما ك انا غيرت ايه فقررت ان انا هاخد
كونشس ديسيجن اركز في اللي انا هلبسه يوم
لبست فستان يوم لبست تيشرت ملونه يوم لبست
بنطلون احمر اي حاجه في اي حته ولقيت ان
انا طريقتي مع نفسي وطريقتي مع الدنيا
وطريقتي مع الشغل والناس اتغيرت فقررت
يمكن ده يكون اتجاهي في الموضه ان انا
استخدم الموضه واللبس والاخريات بتاعه
اللبس والهدوم تبقى التول اللي احنا ممكن
نستخدمها ان احنا نحسن من صحتنا
النفسيه ستايل هي اول شركه في العالم
والشركه الوحيده نمسك الخشب اول شركه
والشركه الوحيده في العالم اللي بتستخدم
علم النفس في الموضه لتحسن الصحه النفسيه
فال الادوات اللي احنا ممكن نستخدمها
والعلاقه ما بين العلم النفس او الحاله
النفسيه او الصحه النفسيه واللبس بتبقى عن
طريق الالوان بتبقى عن طريق الست بتبقى عن
طريق القماش كل التفاصيل بتختلف ما بين
شخص
والتاني اكتر حاجه انا لاحظتها في الكلاين
بتوع يلد ان هم بيبقوا ستات ورجاله عدوا
في فيز ترانزيشن في حياتهم بمعنى ممكن
يبقوا مثلا بنات او ولاد لسه مخلصين جمعه
وداخلين شغل ممكن تبقى مثلا زوجه لسه
متجوزه وبتحاول تلاقي شخصيتها بعد الجواز
او ممكن يبقى مثلا راجل لسه والد وحاسس ان
هو مش لاقي نفسه بعد الخلفه انا اصغر
كلاينت كانت عندي كان عندها 23 سنه ولغايه
النهارده اكبر كلاينت عندي عنده 5 سنه في
الاول لما ابتديت الشركه كان في ريزستنس
عالي اوكي بالذات لما كنت شغاله في مصر
كان في ريزيستنس ان انا بقول فاشن وسايكي
وموضوع السايكولوجي زي ما قلنا كان لسه
اهبو شويه فالناس ريف بس بالوقت لما لما
الدنيا عدت وانا برضو يعني ابتديت اظهر
شويه الحمد لله وبقيت اتكلم اكتر في وسط
الناس وبقيت اسافر اكتر بقى عندي كلاينت
كتيره حول العالم فالموضوع ابتد يعني
يتشهر شويه انا ابتديت الشركه علشان اساعد
ناس كانت تعبانه زيي فانا كنت عايزه الناس
تستخدمني انا كنت عايزه الناس تطلب ان انا
اساعدهم انا انا انا يعني انا ستايل
انقذتني في حياتي 100% فانا عايزه اساعد
الناس
تانيه